cool I'm getting the thumbs up I think
we're good to go we're good Tien yep
cracking awesome
so hi everybody uh thanks for coming to
my talk this morning because there's
some really good talks on in those other
rooms so there was a moment where I
wondered if anyone was going to walk
through that door so I'm feeling quite
pumped now which is really good and it's
so good to be back to an in-person
conference as well so I that's also
fabulous
um so today we're going to be talking
about Azure active directory uh jwt's
oidc
pkce claim Scopes all these fabulous uh
identity Concepts uh so I'll give you a
little bit of information about myself
before we get cracking uh my name's
Graham and I work as a Cloud solution
architect at Microsoft
um I've been there for about two years
now but to be honest with you taken an
architect title was a little bit kind of
like weird I've been a developer
engineer for 25 years before that and
managed to resist being an architect but
it we are that's okay I still managed to
keep relatively uh Hands-On which is
good
now in those 25 years I've seen a lot of
different ways of dealing with identity
authentication and authorization you
know if you think back many many years
ago well you we all used to roll our own
username password databases right pretty
insecure stuff but we had the every
application had its own username
password database not a good place to be
in then we had active directory a lot of
people might still have to use that
today uh it's still everywhere really
but um you know we fast forward we go
through ldap I don't know anyone in here
has tried to roll their own secure token
server uh that's a barrel of fun and uh
really really unpleasant experience if
you've ever tried that and about 15
maybe 10 15 years ago there was a real
change in the industry where this thing
called oauth 2 suddenly came along and
anyone who's been in the Ws star WS
Federation world will know that that was
a cruelly horrible place to be in like
really really disgusting really
complicated just Enterprise to the
extreme and all of two came along with
the idea of really simplifying a common
story which was I've got something like
Facebook I've got a third-party client
I've got users who have data on Facebook
how did they access that
now luckily most applications today
start with of2 or IDC it's it's super
simple to get going on it right and what
I don't want to do today is take you
through that kind of let's get started
let's set an application up uh in my job
at Microsoft it's not uncommon for me to
get calls from customers who have got
problems with their oidc flows and what
always strikes me is that whenever we
set this up there's about three
different things that are involved in it
we've got Azure active directory it
could be any identity server to be
honest it could be off zero it could be
your own custom rolled duende whatever
it doesn't really matter but there's
this thing it's managed by a team we've
got our client applications
and then we have our users and we always
have teams that focus on those
individual boxes but where it gets
complicated is that everything has to be
just right between those three boxes for
everything to work and when it's not
people often don't know where to look or
how to go about diagnosing these issues
so that's really the main focus for my
talk today so I want to cover the tools
and techniques and show you some of the
common classes of errors that I see all
the time in the wild when people are
trying to set these photos up
we're going to talk about a flow called
pkce so if you're building web
applications or native applications it's
something that if you haven't heard
about you really want to start thinking
about moving to it
we're going to break down jwts have a
look what's inside them and we want to
think about how those Concepts in those
tokens relate to Identity and
authentication and authorization
and finally we'll look at Scopes and
groups and roles and have a think about
what they are and again how we can use
use those to kind of build authorization
into our applications
now when I do a talk I kind of like to
come up with a scenario to hang my talk
off and I gave a smaller version of this
in December and it was Christmas so I
kind of had a bit of a theme going on
with Santa Claus and uh how do we make
sure Christmas is a success so I'm gonna
re-badge that today because it's
Australia and Christmas in July is
obviously coming up so we're going to
use a fictitious application that Santa
and his else built to show you the kind
of errors and how to go about diagnosing
them
and here it is
now it's a really common uh type of
thing that I see in customers
essentially Santa used to use an
application called Santa web to manage
Christmas so that would handle problems
like the traveling Center problem how
does you get around all those houses on
Christmas Eve that's quite complicated
naughty nice lists very very complicated
business logic that is locked up inside
a legacy application Heritage
application let's call it in this case
Santa Webb was written in ASP web forms
it's pretty old it had its own clunky
username password
and Santa was managing a lot of
infrastructure so he decided to move all
of this into that North Pole data center
I think I've called it the Azure North
Pole data center I don't think we have
an Azure North Pole data center
um but it'd be kind of cool if we did
and in doing that the elves turned Santa
Webb into a pass put it made it run on
app service platform as a service
whatever it doesn't matter which one it
is
but they also look to do a few extra
things you see Santa was going for a
digital transformation at the time just
like most customers most companies out
there in the wild today
so they Outsource their identity they've
decided to use Azure active directory to
do that and they've realized that the ux
is clunky so they wanted to unlock the
possibility of new user experiences so
what they've done is they've created a
whole bunch of apis
which are decoupled from the asp.net web
forms
to support new modern experiences that
we want to build on top of that now just
so happens there's another cracked team
of elves who fancy themselves as a user
experience deliverers and they're very
competent in react in this case so they
want to build Santa light which is a
single page application and it's gonna
consume those apis from Santa web to
make Christmas a beautiful experience
so the idea is they're going to use oidc
authentication flow to sign users into
that application
and then they're going to use oauth2 and
get access tokens
to call Santa web apis on behalf of else
and Center
so uh one of the key things in there is
a word called token as we'll see through
this talk tokens are really the core
currency of identity authentication and
authorization when we're dealing with a
wolf and oidc
so that's the example I'm going to use
and what we're going to do is we're
going to have a mix of kind of coding
and a bit of kind of talking and showing
you those tools and techniques to help
find out what's going wrong because I've
heard on the ground that they have some
issues so we probably should jump into
the code
and see if we can find out what's going
wrong to help the elves
okay
so let's start in the s
code as it's gonna work well look at
this the demo got straight away there we
go awesome cool now uh the else decided
to use react to write that application
and when they started they were faced
with their first choice they had to make
so whenever you're dealing with oauth2
you don't want to roll your own library
to handle tokens and deal with all the
validations and checks and balances
because it looks deceptively simple on
paper but there's a whole bunch of
security things that are built into
those tokens so you're best off going
for a third-party library to help you
deal with that now in the Microsoft
space we have two we have one called
adul and we have one called M cell
and it just so happens that the else
made the right choice in that in this
scenario they decided to go with M cell
we can see that inside their
package.json they've chosen a dependency
called uh whoopsie
M cell browser and MSL react in this
case now that's great because msel
supports more modern
secure flows which are not supported by
Adel
so be very be very confident when you
make this choice that M cell is the
right way to go uh the reason I brought
this up is because I was doing a search
on npm the other day which is the node
package manager and it was quite
interesting to see
well I'll see if I can make my mouse
work
that when you go to uh a dial node on
npm
in the last week there were four hundred
and eleven thousand downloads of that
package that has essentially been
deprecated for about the last nine
months it's on life support so that's a
lot of potential applications out there
that are using inherently insecure flows
and that's not really a place where you
want to be that's okay the else chose
right they've gone with uh encel
so when they started they had to
set a couple of little parameters inside
their code to wire this all up and to
get it going uh it's pretty
straightforward this is kind of a bare
bones setup for an M cell application
there's two bits of information we need
both really common
um uh definitions inside oidc we've got
the authority and the client ID
now the authority tells our ensa library
where it needs to go to deal with
authentication and authorization
scenarios now in this case it's Azure
active directory so everything goes to a
host name called
login.microsoft.online.com now if you're
off xero you roll your own identity
server that's going to be a little bit
different in fact on those types of uh
service you tend to have your own
dedicated hostname we don't have that in
aad we have a common host log in
microsoftonline.com and then there's a
grid after it so that's your tenant ID
now aad is a massively multi-tenanted uh
identity platform so there are lots of
other customers that also are inside
there so that's just how we can make
sure that it's you that we're working
with when we are doing uh authentication
scenarios as opposed to other customers
now the second bit of information is
called the client ID so this is a really
again common comp Concept in oidc flows
in that every application that wants to
either get tokens or look at tokens
inside of 2 is referred to as a client
so again you'll have a client for every
single application be it a backend
server or a single page application that
you build and these all have to be
registered inside Azure active directory
it's the first bit of configuration that
we need to line up so if you just
remember
a47 and ve3
we're going to quickly jump into the
portal
and have a look at those inside aad so
this is Graham weld my own aad tenant
and you can spin one of these up really
easily uh in fact if you're in an
Enterprise it's quite often useful to
spin up your own tenant because you can
then do a lot more like I'm quite
restricted there's a lot of things
inside AED I can't do inside my company
tenant but I can in my own for a
learning experience it's a really really
good idea but here's my tenant ID a47
and then we have these things called app
registrations
now aad doesn't just do oidc it does WS
Federation it does saml it does a lot of
different authentication mechanisms but
the predates are worth two so it's the
first point of confusion we don't call
them clients in ad we call them app
registrations but Santa Lite is the be3
one down here
and as long as those two bits of
information your tenant ID and your
client ID map up and you can see we even
call out it's your application but yeah
all right it's really a client idea as
far as oidc is concerned then we're now
in a situation where we can start to
authenticate users
so let's jump into our amazing I told
you they were a good team of designers
that we had were the elves uh this is
satellite
and we're going to start a sign in flow
and see what happens
so we click on the button and the
internet's working so that's a good
start we instantly get taken to log in
Microsoft online with a47 which is our
tenant ID and there's a bunch of query
stream parameters that we'll look at in
a minute but the point is satellite has
now taken as a way to aad to start the
sign-in process so I'm going to go and
grab centers credentials
and we get prompted a few usernames and
passwords so again
uh so this is azure active director
that's providing this UI so uh and you
can't customize this one but if you're
using b2c which is the consumer identity
then you can customize uh that a lot
more so
um yeah there's there's gets a little
bit confusing we can talk more about
that offline if you want as well b2c and
aad
so we click the sign in
now the first thing that happens is aad
has been asked by Santa light to ask the
user to consent to provide it some
information so this is the Crux of oauth
2. basically I'm a user I want to use a
third party that wants to do something
with my identity so it asks Azure active
directory to ask me on its behalf to do
that
in this scenario I am being asked
that santalight wants to
sign in and read my profile
so let's click that set on that
and oh straight away now this is a
really really simple problem to solve
but I do see it all the time
so being told that the redirect URI
satellite local test for me does not
match what's inside Azure active
directory
now if we go back to the start of oauth
2.
let's think about what's going on here
I'm an application I'm being directed to
Azure active directory to do something
to sign in when that's done aad needs to
take me back to my application and send
back some information which is one of
these tokens that we spoke about
in the olden days oauth 2 said nothing
about where that core bike had to be so
a lot of off-service supported what we
call Wild Card redirects or open
redirects but that's a really bad
security hole imagine if the Grinch span
up his own Santa light copy looked like
Santa light and he could get an elf to
go and sign in in Azure active directory
which would then blindly redirect to
grinch.localtest.me and pass an identity
token or an access token right you can
start to see how Christmas could get
spoiled because now that tokens in the
hand of the Grinch
so
for Azure active directory to complete a
sign-in we need to not only tell it at
the point of doing the sign in where to
redirect to but it has to understand
where those redirects are up front and
if it doesn't know the redirect it won't
do it for you so that closes the
security hole it's it's one of the areas
where open ID connect actually really
kind of not just fixes but makes a lot
of the original oauth 2 it locks it down
it makes it much more uh safe to use
so in this scenario we're going to go
back into the portal
in Azure active directory
and we're going to go to
should have got a piece of paper for my
mouse mat we configure redirect Uris
against the application and in this case
we can see we've got one single page
application
and straight away you can see that this
is not the one that was requested by
that app it's actually got sign in oidc
so I'm guessing that else we're
originally using like an asp.net
server-side application potentially
that's a common URL we see in them so
this one's pretty straightforward we're
going to remove the suffix that we don't
want and we're going to save that
and we're going to go back to our
application
Center light
and we're going to do the sign in again
and Santa
lessons on my next talk make sure to
have a mouse mat by the computer
my Optical Mouse doesn't like this and
boom we're in
my application knows that it's Santa so
what just happened
okay well uh there's a few ways we can
have a look at the different URLs and
the different payloads that were invoked
to make this work I'm going to use a
tool called Fiddler okay but first of
all let's have a quick look on a
PowerPoint slide of what's going on here
so
we start off with our single page
application we click the login button
the first thing that happens is we get a
302 redirect
this takes us to aad with three main
bits of information we've got what the
application wants aad to do which is in
this case the sign in our users we've
got the where to send me back to that's
the redirect URI and then we've got a
whole bunch of information around
security concerns like State and nonses
and things like that that just help with
the checks and balances to make sure
that things are okay
now one of two things is going to happen
for a native application depending on
the flow that you're using
if you're in Adel world or you're using
a flow called the implicit flow
Azure active directory is going to send
you back to Santa light with a token
now that's how can normally is stored in
something like a hash fragment
I was not recommended anymore it's got
real security concerns around it with
that token inside that fragment
so to give you a few examples of that
let's say you're in an Enterprise that
has got some uh SSL traffic sniffing
firewall or something like that it might
intercept this and log the URLs to disk
so that could be a potential source of
an ID token being leaked in there
because it's in the URL
or if you're a native application I
don't know who's done native apps here
but you can configure application
specific protocols on your apps such
that if you invoke a URL on your device
that will launch your application
now the problem with those is that
unless you're Google or Facebook you
don't get dibs on that application URI
like you can specify it but someone else
can have the same one so whichever app
is loaded by the device first is the one
that's going to respond to that protocol
so if my redirect is my app colon slash
and the Grinch releases an app called my
colon slash he could get the tokens that
way because they made us get posted to
his app by the device
so the problem with the implicit flow is
that token in the fragment is just very
very insecure it's very easy to uh leak
that out another source is uh applicate
third-party JavaScript libraries that
are running in with your application
they can look at the window object for
example and a lot of these off libraries
leave those tokens on the window object
so they can be picked up from there as
well so a lot of places that can leak so
this is not the recommended flow anymore
instead what's come along is a flow
called proof key for code exchange or
pixie as it's shortened to so pixie does
something a little bit different
it doesn't send you back an ID token
inside that fragment
sends you back a code
right and the idea is that that code is
utterly useless to anybody but the
application that requested the sign in
in the first place
now if you've done any award for oidc
you might have seen this before with the
server-side application where the same
thing happens the auth server sends you
back a code but in that scenario your
application uses a shared secret to
switch that code out for a token with
the authorization server now the problem
of a native app of course is that a
native app can't keep a secret
so there's no point bundling up one with
your APK or your IPA package or putting
it in your JavaScript because someone's
going to grab that secret it's not a
secret
so pkc is a little bit different in that
a secret is created on the fly at the
point of kicking off that authentication
request
and what the pkce flow is is that we
send the Char of that one-time secret
back to aad
so aad Associates that sha with the
token that is associated with that code
and it sends the code back out
now in order to exchange that code for a
token you need the plain text that
created that Char in the first place
and if you can present that and the code
then we will give you back the token
okay so it's a way to bind the request
for the token with the receipt of the
token later and it means that we're not
sending that token in hash fragments
everywhere which is a much better
security story
so
what I want to do is use a tool called
Fiddler
which is a networked kind of proxy
debugging tool and we're going to go and
have a look at those flows so when I did
my authentication then I was capturing
traffic Network traffic in the
background so we can see all the HTTP
requests that were going backwards and
forwards
now the initial request for a token
starts off at the authorization end
point on Azure active directory so I'm
going to quickly find those uh calls to
authorization I'm going to take this one
down here and we can click on that and
we can go and have a look at the
parameters that we sent to Azure active
directory
we've told it who we are that's the
client ID at the top that we saw earlier
uh we have this property called scope
scope is a really really uh fundamental
Concept in oauth 2. the idea of a scope
is it's something you can put in front
of an end user that you can ask them to
consent to think of it like satellite
has already got permissions to view
profile details if only those users
would actually let it do that on their
behalf so the scope is a way of asking
for the user to consent for the
application to do something in this
scenario the important ones are open ID
that says it's an openid connect flow
it's authentication not authorization
and then profile so we basically want to
see the user's profile
we have the redirect URI it's a
satellite we just spoke about that one
uh response type is really important we
don't want a token back we want a code
back
and the pkce is the code Challenge and
the code challenge method at the bottom
so code challenge method is s256 this is
a sha256 of something and then the code
challenge is that shot so aad uses that
and when it dishes out the code
which we can see are in should be the
last aad one down here
and let's see if we can have a look at
this one now it's always fun trying to
find the uh
the requests that generate what it is
you're looking for that's the one that
gives the token back okay for the
interest of time there's another flow in
here somewhere where we can see aad
presenting the code back to the
application
and to finish it off center light goes
back to Azure active directory and says
Hey look
here is the code
and
oh that didn't work that's evenly there
we go cool
here is the code and here's the code
verifier so the code verifier was the
plain text that created
the Shah in the first place
and when we get those bits of
information
aad responds by sending us back in this
case a bunch of different tokens but the
important one for authentication is the
ID token now that is basically base64
encoded Json so what we can do is we can
grab this and we can use another tool to
have a look inside it so I'm going to
use a tool called jwt.ms you can also
use jwt.io that's fine as well this
one's nice for aad tokens because it
breaks down all the different claims to
tell you what they actually are but in
essence there's three points to a token
we'll call it the red part the blue part
and the green part
the red part tells us what signing Keys
as your active directory used to sign
this token so that we can trust it's
from aad now there's another call which
I didn't show you where we go to aad and
ask for its signing public keys so we
already have those but it's now telling
us which one it used to sign that
we've got the green part that's just the
digital signature and then we've got the
blue part which is a bunch of
information that we asked for and it's
now responded with
so quickly going through some of this
we start with let's go for the preferred
username so this is an authentication
flow so we can see that it's Center at
groundwater on microsoft.com and we have
the name as well inside there there's a
bunch of time stamps issued at not
before and expires as well and there is
a version which is always a source of
confusion in aad we have two versions
version one and version two of our
endpoints and then we have V1 and V2
tokens if you use msel you always hit
the V2 endpoint if you ask for an ID
token the version of the token you get
back will always be the same as the
version of the endpoint that you hit so
V2 endpoint will get you a V2 ID token
that's different for Access tokens but
that's the way these ones work they're
much the same to be honest with you VT
tokens are a bit smaller
uh than V1 tokens the other really
important bit of information in any
oauth 2 token is the AUD or the audience
claim
now in this scenario the audience B3 is
the same client ID as my satellite
application that was registered inside
aad and the golden rule of oauth tokens
is that if the audience isn't you then
you shouldn't really be using that token
because it was never meant for you
and there's a really good example of
that in tokens that are issued uh to
call our Microsoft graph apis so I've
had customers call me before and tell me
that their istio JWT validation plugin
was failing and they want to know why
and they're trying to validate a graph
API token but it's signed in a very
weird way in the I think they they
create a signature and then they add
something else to the Token after the
signature is created so you can't
validate them basically but the point of
it was that well you're not the audience
so it's kind of not yours to use or
validate is that token
um and that's a really really useful
thing to know especially if you get
weird issues like that but look that's
the identity token and
uh that's the pkce flow and how all of
that hangs together
so with that we're going to move on to
the next
thing so we've signed in we know who the
user is so the next thing you want to
start doing is calling those apis that
have been exposed by Santa web so we've
got a button up here which is to add
Graham to The Naughty Nice List and
let's click on that one and see what
happens
okay so let's put in Santa's password
come on
okay so it's another day's aad consent
windows but this one's a little bit
different to the one we saw a minute ago
this one is now saying that the app
would like to change the Naughty Nice
List on Santa web
so this is another example of a scope
what's going on here is that Santa Webb
has exposed an API or a set of apis to
deal with managing the Naughty Nice List
and Santa like the client wants to
access that this is an example of
incremental consent by the way so it's
an application where as we want to do
things we're going to start asking the
user for extra bits of consent as
opposed to asking for everything up
front because that can be a bit daunting
as a user right if you log in to view
some information and you get asked to
edit and delete and all these kind of
you know higher privilege permissions so
this is just going to ask at the point
in time
but where's that scrub come from what
what is it well we can see there's an
application which is called Santa web so
let's go and find that inside aad and
have a look at that
so we're going to go back up to Graham
world
and this time we'll go into Santa web
and we're going to go into the explosion
API section
and what we should be able to see is
that if all goes well
hahaha
oh it's kind of my first demo gotcha to
180 don't let me down
okay
as far as an API perfect there we go
we're back in
the elves have already been here and
they've defined three scopes on this
application we've got Naughty Nice List
Right naughty nicest read and present
delivery route dot right
now
Scopes are all there for the end user
experience
Scopes don't necessarily mat one to one
to the back end apis so there might be
15 or 20 apis involved in managing the
naughty nice list but we wouldn't want
to be prompting an end user for each and
every one of those because that consent
experience is just going to be too much
to take you know you're asked for a list
of 50 apis to consent to yeah sure
whatever so Scopes allow us this to
create something that makes sense in
front of a user and then that may map to
multiple apis behind the scenes
but in this as far as aod is concerned
it's really just a piece of text it's a
scope right there's nothing that special
about it and we can have a whole bunch
of these against say API if we want to
against an application sorry
now do you see their prefix with API
colons slash Santa web
so whenever we create an application
inside Azure active directory there are
a bunch of different IDs that uniquely
identify that which can be a bit weird
at times we have the application or the
client ID we have an aad object ID and
there's another piece of information
that we can specify that's called an
application URI
whenever we ask for a scope from Azure
active directory we can't just ask for
the name of the scope in this case
naughty nice list.read we have to fully
prefix it with the applications URI
followed by the scope name
now that's a little bit different to say
or zero where when you ask for a scope
there's another piece of information you
send which is the resource that you want
to get a token for because they're JWT
and oauth access token only applies to
one audience there's only one API we can
give this token to which means that all
the Scopes have to be from that API so
it's a little bit strange in aad in that
you can ask for a token with Scopes from
multiple apis but it will reject that
request and just say no no it has to be
from the same API
now in this scenario I've explicitly set
my application ID URI to be API Santa
web
and then if we go and look at the react
code on the Naughty Nice List button
uh we can see that I'm using a m cell
method called acquire token pop-up where
I'm asking for API Santa web present uh
naughty nice list.write
so let's go and
now I'm just going to cancel this I had
some issues with this one the other day
where my actual token request expired so
let's kick it off again
and see if we can get a response from
aad
will upset the consent
and we get a token back
and that's now going to try and call the
API in the back end and we get an okay
an unauthorized response so that's
interesting right something looks okay
we've got a token but there's a problem
somewhere else
so let's start by grabbing the token and
we're going to drop it into jwt.ms
and have a look at it
so it's a bit different this is a V1
token we can see down here but let's not
worry about that too much it's just a
bigger token it's still an access token
not much difference uh we've got this
SCP property in here now so that's the
Scopes that the user has consented to so
we can see that uh Santa in this case
has said yep you can call the Naughty
Nice List on behalf of me icon Center
that
the other one I want to call out is the
audience at the top
so in this scenario the audience has now
changed to API call on Santa web
so in an access token the audience will
be that fully qualified application URI
on the scope that you asked for that
there's a little caveat in that you can
ask for another scope prefix of the
client ID and it will then give you a
token with the client ID as an audience
but on the whole you'll use the
application ID URI so this this looks
pretty good to me I've got a token
um but for some reason something has
failed so I'm going to go to the back
end application now and and see what
happens so this is a net core
application we're using a library called
microsoft.web.identity and we've had to
configure it with three bits of
information pretty similar to the MSL
client uh just different names we use
the tenant ID which was the Grid at the
end of The Authority we've got the
instance which just points to Azure
active directory and we have the client
ID which in this case is the unique ID
of Santa web and we have nothing else
inside there but if we look at the log
file what we can see
is that we've been told our audience
validation failed idx 10214
so I see this a lot with audience issues
in Azure active directory it's a quirk
of aad especially the Microsoft
libraries in that if you don't
explicitly specify an audience
we will kind of make one up based off
other data that we expect those tokens
to have
uh in the portal you can ask for a
default application ID URI and we just
set it to API called slash and then the
grid of your client and that's what aad
sorry that's what Microsoft web identity
will expect on the token if you don't
sell it otherwise
um there's a subtlety as well there's a
weird bit of code in the backend library
that says if it's a V1 token I expect
API colon client ID if it's a V2 token I
expect the client ID that's one of a
source of confusion that I've seen uh
surprise a lot of people doing this but
in this scenario
all we have is a controller asp.net
and you can see we've got a post method
to The Naughty Nice List and at the
moment it's just got a required scope on
there so so uh what we want to do is
inside our app settings we're going to
tell
Microsoft web identity what the
audience should be on the token so it's
just API card on slash Santa web and
then we'll restart the application and
we will try that again and see what
happens
foreign
let's go back to here
and
add ground to naughty nice list
the default isn't to always prompt you
every time by the way I've just done
this to make the demos a bit easier we
actually will cache tokens in the
background to make things a bit better
so if all goes good perfect so that's
the second issue I see is audience is
not set up correctly if you're using
Azure app Service as well this pops up a
lot if you're using the authentication
feature that we have built into it so
you have to be very explicit on the
audiences with that and I've had quite a
few calls where it's it's not set up
properly so it's just one to be aware of
but again we can see the tokens we can
look at the configuration and the floors
and get a good picture on why things
aren't working
so this is awesome uh we have managed to
Now call the downstream API with an
access token
um so I've heard there's another problem
though so I'm going to log out center
now there's a fairly cheeky elf in there
who's called Alabaster and he's been
digging around this application and has
realized something what he's discovered
he said if he signs in
which is the same flows and everything
and he can consent uh
to the same permission that Santa has
been consenting to which is to manage
the Naughty Nice List now Alabaster is
really not a senior elf so he's got no
business to be inside this part of the
system but
he can get prompted for the consent
and he can call the API
now this is something in Azure active
directory to be aware of which is that
as a user well let's start with the
application if there's a permission
configured on an API
then it's really the application can
prompt anybody to consent for that
permission right so just because you can
consent someone if they want to do
something doesn't mean they're actually
allowed to do that so Scopes aren't
permissions right at the end of the day
Scopes are really there just to get
delegated consent to act on behalf of a
user it doesn't mean that user is
necessarily able to do that thing
okay Scopes aren't permissions now some
authorization servers do actually allow
you to map users to Scopes so I think
identity server is one way you could
literally create a scope and then
restrict which users could even be shown
uh to ask for consent
but with aad uh if you're a user if
you're allowed to use an application we
don't restrict which Scopes you are
allowed to consent to we will give you a
token with them in so what are we going
to do
well there are a few different ways I
can think to solve this problem right
the first is fairly old school we have
active directory groups who doesn't love
seeing your name in about 1500 A.D
groups that have been defined over like
30 years of an Enterprise for
applications that no longer exist even
anymore right it's it's pretty painful
it involves the ADT which is normally
quite painful to make changes in ad
which probably not a bad thing to be
honest with you but it's very detached
from your application is active
directory active directory is like an
organizational concern right and in my
opinion ad groups should really
represent quite high level
organizational constructs so maybe that
is that I'm a developer that's fairly
organizational level or somebody works
in marketing or there's a mentors group
they seem like really good natural fits
for ad groups not very low level
application concerns there's a bigger
problem with jwts and active directory
groups as well which is that when you're
in an ad group we start putting those
groups on every token that we send back
which is has you as the subject
so
those groups grow and grow and grow and
grow the tokens get bigger and bigger
and bigger and then we hit a limit and
at that point in time we don't put any
more groups inside that token
so that could leave you in a scenario as
an application where if you're lucky the
group might be in the token if you're
not you might have to make another call
off to graph to work out if the user is
really in the group that you want to
find them in
so not a great place to be in now in aad
we have another construct which is much
a much better fit for this that's called
a roll
so roles are like groups that are really
scoped to your application inside Azure
active directory and they give us a much
better location to put application
concerns
and the idea is that we can Define roles
against an app and we can assign users
and groups to them and then when we get
a JWT back for the audience of that
application we will show you the roles
that that user is in that are defining
the application
so they're pretty straightforward to
Define let's go into Santa web
and we have this tab down here called
app roles so if we select that we can
see there are two Define we've got Santa
World employee and Santa World senior
employee so the idea is that you should
only be able to manage the naughty nice
list if you're a senior employee
so how do we get users into that
well
we've talked about applications so far
but aad has got this other wonderful
thing that goes hand in hand with an
application that depending on which day
of the week it is either called a
managed application an Enterprise
application or a service principle
each name really makes very little sense
to me and uh it took me a while to
actually understand what was going on
but the idea is that an aad application
is really just definition it's metadata
it's not a thing that you actually
really interact with or you hang users
off or users sign into
instead what happens is that for every
application if you want to use that
inside your aad tenant you need to
create what's called a let's call it a
service principle which kind of goes
hand in hand with that it's literally
like a uh the manifestation of your
application inside a directory and
that's where we can start hanging things
like real users and blocking users from
accessing the application in the first
place looking at who's signed into it
all kind of things like that conditional
access are done against the service
principle not the application
um there's another way we can set an
application of which is in a what we
call a multi-tenant form and it probably
makes more sense in that world because
with a multi-tenant application we only
Define it once but then we can have
other directories that want to consume
the term a SAS provider they want to use
my SAS service they can create the
service principle in their directory
where they can assign users an access
and conditional access and things like
that
so when we want to assign users to a
role we have to go into the managed
application service principle Enterprise
application whatever we want to call it
and in here we can effectively go to
users and groups
and we can start getting much more
specific about who can access this
application or indeed if anyone can
access this application
so let's go and find Santa
and we will select Center
and when we go to role
the only roles that we are offered are
the ones that were defined against the
application object so in this case I'm
going to make Santa a senior employee
it's probably more than a senior
employee's Center and we will assign
and now let's go back to Santa light
emsel and we'll sign out and sign back
in the center
in
and let's go and find Center
I didn't remember it
and
sign him in
now we'll click to add into the Naughty
Nice List and we'll have a quick look at
the JWT first of all that comes back
accept
there's your token let's put that into
the third one over here
uh so this is an access token yeah yeah
and then you can see now that we get
this extra array comeback of strings
which is the roles that Santa's assigned
to now what we can leverage in the back
end API is we're using standard
um
asp.net authentication authorization
here so we can start to use our bog
standard authorize attribute
and we can say that we want the in this
scenario it's the roles that we're
interested in
and then we just go and find that
particular role senior contributor
I was a senior employee oh man
what's going on there then
ah okay yeah that's
My Demo bad basically there's a human
visible version of a role and then
there's the actual
um sort of key of the role that you get
back so I think in this scenario what
I've done is the senior employee is
actually called senior contributor so
that's the one that comes back in the
token thanks thanks for pointing that
with our Booksy
okay great so we are going to check for
that particular role in the token so now
when we run this
then for Santa all is going to go well
and we're going to be able to call that
API but if we were to get a token as
Alabaster then of course we're not going
to have that particular role inside the
token and the authorization step will
fail
so uh she has to kind of finish that one
off
[Music]
in this scenario I think it worked last
time anyway because we didn't have the
orph on there
and
happy days hopefully ah felt a fetch
I'm not sure what's going on there but
anyway that's okay uh you'll have to
trust me on that one uh in the interest
of kind of not
fixing my broken code that one should
have worked and if we do the same as
Alabaster we don't have the role inside
the token so everything fails
so really that's what I had to walk
through today
um I think we've covered a fair bit if
anyone's interested there's the crazy
code inside
microsoft.web.identity which looks to
specific versions of tokens and then
hardwires a different expected audience
depending on which one it is there's a
link on the slide deck as well uh to
that code if anyone interested in that
but ultimately Scopes aren't permissions
and that's the really important thing I
want to get across now really roles
aren't great for permissions either
they're good for segregating users into
your application
but as your business logic starts to get
more and more specific then you really
don't want to be Outsourcing that into a
third party like aad like you don't want
to get into a trap of having roles
called something like can transfer more
than a hundred dollars or is allowed to
transact on a Monday right that is
business logic concern and either get
that inside your application or look to
something like a policy server
potentially if you want to Outsource
that there's a good talk tomorrow
morning but uh Jason is doing early
about asp.net core authorization policy
so if that's something that you're
interested in to take that next level
into getting application business
authorization rules then I fully
recommend going to that talk
um but that is everything from me for
today so really appreciate you all
coming and
um so we have a few minutes potentially
for questions if there are any so thanks
you mentioned oidc but um
yeah
sure right so
um in the beginning there was all off
too and and oauth 2 was a very loose
framework on how to build an
authorization framework and it was
possible to be like you know adhering to
a wolf too whilst having quite different
implementations of your uh different
implementations auth2 is also just an
authorization protocol right so its main
purpose was to get delegated consent of
a user really to consume their Facebook
profile
but it said nothing about Authentication
so what happened is a lot of the big
providers built their own authentication
apis and used the wharf2 to get tokens
to access those so you had this like
proliferation where signing with Google
signing with Facebook signing with this
service they all did it in a slightly
different way the claims are all
slightly different in the tokens
so oidc came along and really started to
uh come up with a more standard
compliant way of implementing a warf2 as
a framework so that might be a case of
saying well look of2 said you could do
this and you could do that and maybe you
could do this but you don't need to
worry about that oidc said Nana this is
how you do it and then it also added
this new token called an ID token which
basically fixed fixed in quotes the
authentication problem and gave us
standards compliant way to just work out
who somebody is without asking them to
access another API
so I I quite often interchanged and I'll
say oh two or I'll say oigc and I never
really know which one to say because
it's not like it's an umbrella it's not
like it's a replaces a wolf too it's
more like it has these extensions two or
two and it also
um just kind of makes it a little bit
more concrete around how to implement
oauthu
so when you look at Azure active
directory for example I refer to it as
like an oidc compliant authorization
server that will give you also oauth2
tokens as well as identity access tokens
but I'm happy if anyone else like so a
lot of what I know about this I work
with some really smart people at Bank
West a few years ago and learned a lot
from their identity teams so I'm happy
if anyone else in the room wants to like
extend that answer then please go for it
because uh yeah
yep sure
an RSC a request for comment I think it
stands for so
um if you want this is a good one I'm
sure someone will give a much better
answer for this
um so you have an idea and you want to
think about standardizing that idea so
the general approach is we put out as an
RFC and then it will have a lot of kind
of debate and discussion and feedback go
through various versions until it kind
of hits a point where it's considered
you know stable enough and the
controversy has died down so
um
yeah and then different things are
referred to as different RSC numbers so
private Network addresses like RSC 1819
you know it's where a bunch of people
just said not these IP addresses we are
going to say they are private use only
they are not public and that's
um pretty much standardized in RFC 1819
so oauth to an irdc also have rfcs that
go with them as well
yeah right so it's normally a coalition
of the Willing so you'll find a lot of
the rfcs will have people uh if if there
are Enterprise products involved they'll
often have representation from the
vendors of those products but also they
may be you know academics just people
that are really interested in that
domain so I think it's kind of a public
domain thing I'm not sure if there's a
method to choose who gets to contribute
in it or not
um that's possibly a level I I don't
really uh know at that point but yeah
um
in the aad console so you're working in
the section called app registration yeah
how does that differ from the Enterprise
applications section which is also used
to set up xso with Apple
yeah right okay so
um
the app so which bit of it in particular
was it you were thinking about in there
so
I haven't um
in this way exactly but I haven't worked
in the Enterprise applications section
when you're registering like a
third-party
um oh yeah right okay cool
yeah okay sweet yeah so there's some
similarities yes
yeah right right so what you're probably
doing there is setting up a multi so a
multi-tenant application so when it
comes to SAS providers I was doing some
work with one the other day they own the
application registration right so you
never see that part of the portal you
can't access it it's inside the SAS
provider's tenant but what you can do is
you can create that you can crash these
links that allow in aad administrator to
create an instance of a service
principle that represents that
application in their directory so it's
possible that that's where you're at is
inside that service principle that
represents a third-party application and
that's where you can start assigning
users to it
um yeah so it's more about whether it's
a third-party application
something in the house that you're
building specifically to work with right
yeah yeah linking something that yeah so
if you want to do sign inflows in aad
then there has to be an application
somewhere and there'll be a service
principle in the tenants where you can
sign into that application there are
scenarios where you can have service
principles without applications as well
so if you use Azure and you create a
managed identity you'll get a service
principle without an application and you
can assign R back to that service
principle for example but yeah if
there's a sign in flow there'll be an
application somewhere
oh yep sorry
um
Federation approach yeah yeah so the
question is around
um multiple identity providers if you
want to build a application that can do
sign-in against all of those can be a
real pain
um I I don't know the Azure active
directory roadmap but I do know that b2c
does support Federation so you can front
a whole bunch of different identity
providers with a b2c sign-in page now
that having said b2c sign in doesn't
give you access to like authenticator
and all that kind of conditional access
stuff so I think there's still some gaps
there but I'm not sure what's on roadmap
for uh
closing those if anything
yeah go for it
yeah I don't think there's much you can
change on ad right so B to C is one way
you can get a lot more customized uh
flows defining your own uis and all that
kind of stuff that having said there
possibly are some parameters you can
tweak to change that experience a little
bit I just haven't done too much on that
so I'm afraid I don't have a great
answer I take it offline and uh
um find out for you
cool
okay so we'll look thank you everyone
for coming and um yeah enjoy the rest of
your conference cheers
[Applause]